Tại vì tôi có 1,2 trăm bấy trửa trang tương nếu đã lấy từ chứng trường.
Đà phần đã lấy từ trên thiết thế,
Mà lo, cách hầm, của những người đã từng gà xuống đã tham gia tập tiếp trứng trường.
Nhóm nghiên cứu đại học thích sách thách Mỹ đã cùng cấp cho các quan trức năng thành bố chỉ mình,
nhiều kỳ vật chính trang và hồ sơ chung các lịch sĩ,
khi xin trong chính trịch bột thân một chiến sấu tắm.
Các bạn nhận này, gồm buồn sơ về ba, ki vật lịch sĩ,
sơ độ chung các thay mốt lịch sĩ tại bệnh diện các bệnh sấu a,
cùng hồ sơ dạy mạch bật sách đơn vị trình sấu hay,
liên quan đến các hiệp vật được phát hiện tại công việc lịch sĩ.
Trong tờ viết được một cái bóc cao,
chính tệ hồ sơ này,
tôi là nó không phải là bằng cóp nữa,
nhưng mà nó lỏ bằng duy nhất một chiếc thật cóp nữa.
Điểm lại cho đến từng nha,
cái lát thư của người chà,
khi bóc cao thì nhập ký của người ăn người ăn người ăn người chì.
Thì nó chó phép, ra đến phần nào viết được,
ăn của mình,
thì chính trường đến như thế nào,
ăn đấm mình,
đủ là hí sin như thế nào,
con của mình,
nó thì xin trong các bóc cao nào thuộc đề các đường với nào.
Chó chúng ta có có thể hồi để phục giấm lại,
cái trên phần của những cái con người này.
Hẹn gố hồ chí mình đang đầy mạnh tìm kiếm,
quy tập và xác định xanh tính hai cót đề sĩ theo chứng dịch năm trong ngày đêm.
Zó bán chỉ đạo quốc gia phát động,
hướng tới kỷ điểm tảm vi năm ngày thương quyết lịch sĩ,
hai bệnh thẩn bị 1 chiếm muốn bệnh, hai bệnh thẩn bị hai không hai bệnh.
Tại công việc lịch diễn phường hoa hơn,
sau hơn một tháng tìm kiếm,
dựa trên giữ liệu khiến anh và lời gẻ nhân chứng,
các quan trích năng đã quy tập mười sảo hại của lịch sĩ trong đó một chứng hợp đã sát định được sánh tính.